you know in astronomy we rely heavily on
or visual intuition because of course
because is not an experimental science
we cannot go exactly the place where
these two objects are actually merging
so this is for example a
collaboration between
artists and astrophysicists in trying to
understand well how can I explain
to myself into the public what's
happening because it's certainly
you know train my brain into look at
things in a very different way so now
can see a three-dimensional
visualization
and they try to understand basically the
physics in a different way because I
have tools that I didn't have before
of how to look at a phenomena so high so to
play to be an alchemist with a computer